[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in andrew brandt the sports
illustrated columnist and uh once again
used to be with the packers in the front
office and joins us now all right let me
ask you that let me start there
eli manning
against tony romo
which quarterback do you want
i was a victim of that eli manning one
of those runs you just talked about
so that stays with me dan you know he
came into lambo the 2008 nfc
championship god they were on the road
for four weeks we were expecting to play
dallas who they beat we were ready to go
to dallas and all of a sudden
we're hosting the game
it's going to be minus 5 degrees
we're like this is great we're going to
super bowl
you know and then all of a sudden he
attacks us with plexiglas i remember
that somehow some way we didn't play
well we got to overtime we did because
what was his name the kicker kept
missing
easy extra points and field goals
times
and uh and then brethren pick in
overtime and it brett's last throw with
the packers
um
it was heartbreaking so everything's
judged by personal experience so i don't
want to play eli
that stuck with me but there's certain
guys who are just better in the
postseason a big game like what is it
about
i know it's who you play where you're
playing but like let's start with brett
favre
what's farv
did you consider him great in the
postseason was he different
yeah i mean i think
we've seen the best and worst of farve
in the postseason right we saw that he
had a lot of interception games where he
tried to force things but he has that
resilience
that you saw in the super bowl that he
won and the way he played in major major
games i mean i think all the great ones
dan have this ability to sort of put
aside
all the hype and the nerves and all that
that goes into it certainly brady
certainly aaron they have a chill about
them in these big moments going back to
joe montana i mean i think it's just
that
has carried them all the way from junior
high school all the way up who's the
third best quarterback of all time
you're talking about uh
who's one and two you gotta tell me that
well brady's one yeah
montana two yeah okay so who's three
i mean we talked about them all off
season i'm biased
um i think aaron you know everyone's
gonna judge on super bowls i get it but
aaron's got abilities that i don't think
anyone's ever had
and mahomes has some of that right now
but it's obviously early in his career
but um
two of my guys may go down as third you
know whether farmer rogers you know just
have to look at those i'm biased yeah i
know i get that i get that a little
territorial nothing wrong with that all
right you stated uh
and i don't know if you tweeted this out
but uh you said deshawn watson's not
playing for the texans that that's
that's not gonna there's been
conflicting reports there why do you
think he no longer plays and at what
point do the texans say we know he's no
longer playing and we're going to get
rid of him
yeah listen i'm a lawyer and i always
look at precedent and we've had so much
precedent in the area of conduct with
this commissioner i call him the conduct
commissioner i pointed to examples of
star players now we have a star player
in houston
okay 2010
ben roethlisberger something happened in
the back of a bar with a woman in a
bathroom we still don't know what
georgia investigations there was no
criminal charges ben roethlisberger six
games suspension reduced to four but six
games suspension seven years later 2017
ezekiel elliott something happened with
a woman he wasn't even a cowboy yet but
he had been drafted
um
six games
no criminal charges
six games so if you we've got the same
commission
right the conduct commissioner we've got
a player charged with
20-something crime i'm sorry
20-something civil
and nine or ten criminal complaints
and even if you sort of surmise oh my
god they're all making it up it's a big
conspiracy i mean how does this
commissioner
allow this guy to play anywhere near
past
a six-game suspension
how
how but what if it all goes away what if
i mean
wait
what is the commissioner waiting for how
do we know anything happened with ross
berger and elliot i mean
it's like
yeah but what at what point does the
commissioner have to help out the texans
to say i'm either going to put him on
the commissioner's exempt list we're
going to suspend him or nothing is going
to happen because teams aren't going to
trade until they hear from the legal
office yeah two things i don't know i
don't know what's taken so long because
we hear about women you know maybe the
witnesses aren't being compliant maybe
this or that maybe lisa friel is not
getting the information she wants and
investigating this matter
but to me the texans have to know and
listen dan the texans
can't just sort of slide through this if
they think there's culpable actions
they could have done something and
they're waiting for the commissioner to
leave it to roger that kind of thing the
other part of this you mentioned the
trading teams people talk about
philadelphia i'm like really
really you're going to use this
opportunity to try to get a good deal
and then you're going to sell that to
your fan base
like hey we got him for like one first
but don't worry about that other stuff
we got a great deal i mean you're gonna
sell that to your fan base that includes
half women i mean
i don't see how he plays for anyone this
year until maybe late in the season
texans or otherwise yeah but what
changes late in the he's not going to be
deposed till february nothing's ch
nothing's going to change here unless he
settles all these lawsuits and if he
does
then people are going to still say you
were guilty uh is the team still gonna
go well he was sort of guilty here
i don't get it
i mean the other precedent i point out
is greg hardy and adrian peterson 2014 i
remember they commissioner exemplist and
was was for players coming off like uh
holdouts it was never used for this
so they brought it out of cobwebs and
they said all right we're going to park
these guys
like adrian peterson took a stick to his
son greg hardy beat up his girlfriend we
can't put him out there but we're going
to pay them we're going to park them
i mean
how do they put deshaun watson on the
field this year i i don't get it so
you're right
what's going on how is going to change
and i guess what i'm saying and maybe
you're agreeing with i don't see him on
a field in 2021
you have josh allen getting the new
contract and then we're waiting for
baker mayfield and lamar jackson that
they're next and my point is why do i
have to rush every contract with a
quarterback why does every quarterback
the next one up get more than the
previous one because i don't think lamar
jackson and baker mayfield are better
than josh allen i certainly don't think
baker is and i wouldn't sign baker right
now i need to see i want to see one more
year how does he with stefanski's
offense a running game you know they
they're led by their defense like those
are kind of things that i think are a
little bit tricky it's not like i rubber
stamp baker mayfield and go yep i'm
going to give him what they gave josh
allen where do you stand on the browns
approach with baker
i agree with that and the ravens too i
would wait i know listen i'll talk about
the downside of waiting in a minute but
the reason i wait is what you said and
also
you've got some history now that are bad
decisions and i'm talking about carson
wentz and jared goff we talked about
once a lot
three years right away given the big
extension now they're dealing with cap
consequences for disastrous you know
decisions today why not wait you know
the colts waited four years with andrew
luck and he was great
why not wait the the problem you get is
the personal problem right dan so baker
mayfield and lamar jackson can say wait
a minute
what about you don't think of me the way
bills think of josh allen
but
it also depends on negotiations people
talk about 250 million dollars 100
million guaranteed great josh allen but
they got him for eight years
maybe john maybe they want more of a
prescott deal four years and get another
big bite at the apple
so maybe it's on the on the mayfield
agent or the jackson agent saying
i don't want an eight-year deal you're
not only locked up my whole career so
we'll see where it goes i i agree with
you why you have to jump in after three
years you got next year under contract
and you got the fifth year option
talking to andrew brandt sports
illustrated columnist and uh once worked
with the packers front office there he
is offering a one-hour webinar that's
next tuesday that's august 17th at 8
eastern and uh tell people how they can
sign up for this and uh what is the
agenda
yeah i just saw with everyone go back to
school at all levels from high school to
graduate school and professionals
wanting to get in the business it's a
good time to sort of tell people kind of
behind the scenes stuff and
my thoughts having been on the age
inside the team side so many ways in the
sports business how to get in and
it's really something sort of popular
demand so i'm going to do it next
tuesday night just go to my twitter go
to my uh
androdashbrandt.com
and you can sign up for my newsletter
and of course this webinar getting a lot
of signups be great next tuesday night
thanks dan awesome that's august 17th at
uh 8 eastern great to talk to you again
andrew
always a pleasure dan talk soon thank
you andrew brandt sports illustrated
columnist former front office exec with
the packers